Why young people should do more
confidence in your list?
Well I wore uh.
1 fight against the French state,
for 1 climate action,
I had the ecosy registered in four and a half years,
the departure from the planet in European law.
All the voices of ecology are on this list.
Proposals for young people,
there are plenty,
starting with holding up uh.
Count their voice
since we are asking for the right to vote at age 16.
But we also ask for something like 1 income
Minimum training.
In fact, we are fighting
to have 1 minimum income at the European level that
also concerns young people,
not like in France.
But what we are proposing is that Europe implement,
at least starting with,
1 income for the 18,
25 years old,
which allow them to train,
whatever their initial level,
but to be able to either work by living decently,
or to follow their studies.